now just days before the summit there
are growing concerns about the outcome
of cop26 but the climate crisis is
already here and there's no time to lose
so do leaders need to switch their focus
to what's happening now rather than what
might happen should cop 26 focus on
present problems or future challenges uh
stanley johnson to you first the prime
minister himself said recently that they
may not reach the agreements they need
it's touch and go it's very difficult
what solutions in your opinion should
leaders be focusing on at cop
well i think they've got to go they've
got to go for an agreement on the track
we're on we have to get the world back
bend the curve back so that two degrees
even 1.5 degrees is reasonable but the
other thing is to celebrate i'm optimist
today very good news that china has said
they're going to advance the date or do
our best to advance the date of peaking
that is something i'm not one of these
turnovers they have made a huge effort
they're going to go from peaking to
neutrality in a shorter space of time
than almost any other country in the
world
and dr ella gilbert climate finance
needs to grow 13 times faster to achieve
these climate targets do you think
enough leaders are going to get their
checkbook out at cop26
well i wouldn't like to comment on the
kind of policy negotiations but they
absolutely have to as a scientist i can
comment only really on what's happened
and what is likely to happen
and the truth of the matter is that
we're already seeing huge impacts of
climate change we're already seeing
devastating impacts all over the world
and those impacts are likely to get much
worse if we do not do anything and that
means world leaders putting their money
where their mouth is and actually
implementing those mitigating
climate action proposals so they
absolutely have to um in my mind
and stanley johnson just to you how
concerning is it to you that some of the
biggest polluters either aren't going or
haven't yet uh confirmed their
attendance do you think this is just a
sign that perhaps it won't be taken
seriously enough
no i think we've got a very good there's
a very good show
for us in glasgow i think we are going
to get a good result and the point
you're just making about adaptation
money for developing countries is
perfectly crucial well said because
actually those countries africa whatever
they didn't create the problem and yet
they are going to suffer the impact so
money for adaptation crucial
you